[applause]
so ladies and gentlemen it's just me
we're an extraordinary pleasure to welcome
excellence where angela
merkel chancellor of the federal republic of
germany it's
our conference you're
called upon
to show passion and courage
to shape and structure globalization at this place  and
your suitcases in the bilateral
cooperation then as well as in the
materials deliver these requirements
i think in particular also 15
reduction of the risk of accidents and
occupational diseases set up under your initiative
while the world and europe are at
a crossroads an important dialogue process and
mean the reflection work
achieved
this is illustrated not least by the
white paper that I am a challenge
for the future at the workshop but
on the world opened on march 12 of this year federal president
stein marina in
hesse has the 100th anniversary of the federal
chancellor
[music]
very much  Dear Mr. President,
Ladies and gentlemen, Excellency,
dear general director, better
served than, dear
representatives of the
employees, dear ladies and
gentlemen, you are already a professional company,
humane and fair approaches
also and especially at
the work pds shows people are alone
as  factors of production seen or
can they be
realized the income is enough for a
decent life and
therefore the working conditions people
assistant united in the endeavor and
appreciate the economy has the
people approach childish and not the
other way around the just-year-olds exist
especially on this birthday
the organization congratulates the  feel committed to their
declared goals
have eccentric social justice
an end to the first in the paris
peace conference the others are not all
inquiries and demarcations war guilt
of peace
the boarding school  ional organization of work
the cooperation between the sleep
how can we of germany offers
human loss or political foresight
what is strategic foresight
politicians feel only about
describing what happened back then the place
in prison and comes that in the
decades that followed
european integration became what  an
international peace order
the international labor organization
107 makes the international
labor organization an employers and
governments business in germany
this shared responsibility of
employees employers and governments
that today see themselves as members of
the organization the
trade unions also
have joint responsibility organizations at the beginning of our
on the other hand we have to integrate everything
business growth  do you have the
impression that the social inequalities are
similar and have less than 20
and us work not out
you find yourself on media literacy
like mitt  internally whether
your profession still needs a carpenter where
possible
but not enough political
technologies change not only
do we have to work but of
course there are expectations of the employees
as well as the work york at work so
the home office suite can improve the
compatibility of work  and family
germany traveled expectation
at the same time but also to take
constant availability
how can or artificial intelligence of
course we also work in the
european union ag lines
there have been
social reconciliation of work and family
to parents and caring relatives is
the topic again and again in the last few months  minimum wage also plays a
role german minimum wages also in
view of the standards of the
countries can have in
view of our economy based on the division of labor
with its many
dependencies are taken a reliable
internet summer pacific
joint regular classes benefit
yes  especially the world's leading
industrial nations not enough to
do elsewhere so in every
other
there the government decide together
with the social partners and got which
projects in the area of schengen system 7 and
g 20 we have a special focus
on this
ecided the position of trust
in business  and society are
created and especially in many
poorer countries strengths together they
have reported and thus their
access to women belongs in particular the
professional qualification of
developments can be further promoted
but the same men have not borne fruit in all directions
century against the background of the
challenges posed by climate change
[Music]
this international system of
musical danger relatively many gives
the say operation happened again and again
concrete ideas
the result is a comprehensive
completely since users enormous system
for a fair 25 reccomm  a lot to
do
clearly laid down in it a lot about the principles of
which
one will certainly feel freedom of association the right to
collective elimination prohibition of the
general principle good work work
-related are for a good life
many paths
lead to this but we are still far
too many people in the world  these
paths i have the lock and the
international labor organization the
commitment that has not always been very important
to the fact that this organization like
the international
[music]